- My goal is to simplify complexity.
You have those, like, shower moments,
where you're walking at midnight
in some town in New York City
and you've got these amazing brand ideas,
and then you started thinking, well,
I could really start
doing this, if only X,
and if I had this person, or
if this technology existed.
I think leaders of companies
have to consider themselves editors,
and you constantly have to edit the team.
- He's an American computer programmer
and entrepreneur.
He's widely known as the
co-founder and CEO of Twitter,
as well as the founder and CEO of Square.
He has an estimated net
worth of 1.2 billion dollars.
He's Jack Dorsey, and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Rule #1 is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
And as always, if Jack says something
that really resonates with you,
make sure to leave it in the comments
and put quotes around it
so other people can benefit
and be inspired, as well.
- It's kind of cliche, but, just do it.
A lot of time is spent
thinking about something
And talking about it.
- Yeah.
- But when you actually
get something down,
either on paper or in code, or...
You know, in front of someone.
That's when things start happening.
And you're going to
make a lot of mistakes.
The important thing is
that you make decisions
and you keep moving forward.
But you have to get it out there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- You have to start, and you have to be
brave enough to take the criticism.
I always go back to the
punk movement from the 70s.
People would get out,
they'd be on the street,
They'd start these bands.
- 'Cause you were a teenager.
- Yeah.
And they would be,
they would be learning in front of people.
They get out on the street,
and it's their first time with a guitar.
And, you know, they're
learning how to play
and they're getting better
and better and better.
- Yeah.
- And I think it's really important
to just get it down.
Do it.
- [Interviewer] Just do it.
- Edit, edit, edit, edit.
My goal is to simplify complexity.
I just want to build stuff
that really simplifies
our base human interaction.
Twitter was around communication,
and visualizing what was
happening in the world
in real time.
Square was allowing everyone to accept
the form of payment that people have
in their pocket today,
which is a credit card.
So we've built the simplest
way to accept credit cards.
It's just this little, tiny device
that we give away for free,
and you just download some
software from the app store,
and you plug it into your
mobile phone or your iPad,
and suddenly you can take credit cards.
So if you're a tax
accountant, or a lawyer,
or a doctor, or, you
know, even a hairstylist,
you can now accept credit cards.
It's really that the users
help decide where we go.
We are the curators of the technology,
and we think we're pretty good at it, but,
and this leads into my third lesson, is,
you need to listen.
You need to be still, and really listen to
what's going on around you.
And let that inform,
and let that inspire your next steps.
- Seems hard to be still and listen
when you've got your,
you have 300 follower,
you're following 300 people or whatever.
- It's extremely hard.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- It's really important
that you're able to step back and
listen to what's going on
and what patterns emerge,
so that you can really consider those
and move them.
I think that's one of the strongest things
you can cultivate as an entrepreneur,
is to, not rely on luck,
but cultivating an ability to recognize
fortunate situations
when they're occurring.
Odeo was a very fortunate situation.
Could've taken that idea,
not told it to Ev, not told
it to Biz, not told it to Noah
and all my other coworkers at Odeo,
and tried to start my own
company with that idea.
But the fortunate situation was that
I was working with some
really amazing people.
And we had a great team.
So, of course, you know, it
makes sense to start there.
The fortunate situation
for Square was that
in 2008, the end of 2008,
the entire market was crashing down.
Like all of these
abstractions we built upon,
abstraction upon abstraction
upon abstraction,
in the financial world,
which no single human understood,
were now falling apart.
And suddenly we're getting back to basics,
back to fundamentals.
Management teams were
being asked to leave,
banks were failing, you know,
people were clarifying around, like,
we need to start getting innovative,
we need to stop treating
our customers so poorly,
we need to stop, you know,
encouraging bad behavior to reap fees.
Like, we need to really turn
this whole thing around.
And anytime there's a
recession or a depression,
that's a great time to innovate,
start a company, start a project,
you know, do anything, so.
You know, we recognize that time,
and at the same time, my co-founder, Jim
re-contacted me.
I've known him since he was 15 years old,
he was my boss when I was 15 years old.
And he's like, "Jack,
I want to talk to you.
"I want to build an
electronic car company."
I'm like, that's interesting.
And he was thinking about it because
the car industry was failing as well,
and he was like, why don't we
just give these car companies
to well-seasoned entrepreneurs?
Like why don't we give Ford to Steve Jobs?
- That would be amazing.
- Yeah, it would be amazing.
And like, you know, GM
to Ellison or whatnot.
And he's like, "Also I want to start
"an electronic car company."
I'm like...
That's ambitious.
But, in that moment, we decided
not to start an electronic car company,
but we wanted to do something together.
And we kept having these
weekly conversations
about what that thing was.
And I was researching a lot
with finance and healthcare,
'cause I was looking at, you know,
doing something in those spaces.
And Jim called me one day,
one of our scheduled meetings,
and he said, "I just lost a glass sale."
He's an artist, he sells glass.
"And I lost a sale because I
couldn't accept a credit card."
And here he was, talking on his iPhone,
his general purpose computer,
and I was talking on my iPhone.
And like we couldn't figure out--
- A 1 GHz computer sitting
in the palm of your hand
but no way to accept credit cards?
- Yeah, he couldn't
accept $2,000 from someone
who wanted to pay him.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Like, why is that?
So we decided that we wanted
to answer that question,
and we did a bunch of research,
and I started writing some server code,
and we hired a guy to
write some iPhone code,
and Jim built some hardware,
and in a month, we had a little,
well it was actually quite a big device
that plugged into the
audio jacket of your iPhone
and could swipe the card, take a payment.
It would go through the merchant process
and then generate a
receipt with a map on it.
And I went around, I showed
it to a bunch of investors,
and they were all amazed
that it could even work.
So we decided to really focus on it
and make it a company.
And it really just comes down to
recognizing that fortunate situation,
recognizing the people
around you that could help
and just owning it.
The biggest thing for me on that path is
I need to, I need to draw something out,
and I need to get it out of my head.
I found myself, very early on,
thinking about something, like,
you know, thinking about
this early idea for Twitter,
and saying to myself, "I
could build this awesome..."
You know, you have those,
like, shower moments
or you're walking at midnight
in some town in New York City,
and you've got these amazing grand ideas.
And then you start thinking, well,
I could really start
doing this, if only X,
and if I had this person,
or if this technology existed,
or if this happened, or this happened.
And what I realized I was
doing is I was constantly
making excuses for not working on it,
and then the window had passed,
and then I couldn't do anything.
So I think it's really,
really important to
write it out, or to draw it out.
Or to code it.
But you need to get it out of your head.
And the reason you have to
get it out of your head is
you need to be able to see it on a surface
that is not in your mind.
And once you can see it, and
once you can step back from it,
then you can also decide,
"Eh, you know, this passes my filter."
Passes my, you know, constraints,
so maybe I can show it and
share with some other people.
And then they'll be like, "You know what,
"that's the stupidest idea ever."
And, or, you know, "That's
somewhat interesting,
"but maybe this and this and this."
So the sooner you can do that,
then you have a lot of momentum around it
and you can, you know,
really decide if you want to
commit to it and work on it more
or put it on the shelf for a later date.
And the realization that I
think everyone needs to have
about that latter option,
putting it on the shelf,
is that you can come back to it.
And it'll surface back up
in another piece of work,
or another idea at some
point in your life.
So, having that ability
to close off a chapter
and move on is really, really important.
You can't have all these open threads.
And that's what I realized I was doing.
And that also encouraged
me to really write more,
and to really think about, you know,
what is the story?
How are people coming to this?
And when I show my friends this,
how are they going to react?
And I would write it down.
I would actually treat it like a play.
And when I realized that
I was writing plays,
I read a lot more plays, for style,
and for substance, and for technique.
And I think it's, you know,
I think it's really good.
I think there's another company
that I've always looked
towards for inspiration,
and I know a number of people in this room
probably have the similar company in mind,
which is Apple.
Apple, I think, is run
like a theater company.
It has a great sense of pacing,
it has a great sense of story,
and has a great sense of execution.
And it's all about...
It's all event-driven.
It's all stage-driven.
The stage being a billboard,
or the stage being a keynote,
or the stage being a product launch.
All of it has a very, very cohesive
end-to-end story.
I mean, you think about what happened
when Steve Jobs came back to the company,
the first thing he did is he killed
every product line the
company was working on.
And for two years, they had no product
on the market whatsoever.
All they had were a bunch of posters
all around the world with Steve's heroes.
And it said, "Think different."
And it was just focused
on bringing up the brand
and making people aware
of the brand again,
and how the brand is aligning
to this particular feeling and story.
And then they came out with the iMac,
and then built iTunes, and then the iPod,
and they realized that, wait a minute,
people are carrying music
on their phones now,
so we better build a phone, the iPhone.
So this unfolding of the
plot and the epic story
has been very very interesting to watch,
especially if you look back, you know,
to that time when he
came back to the company.
So I've learned a lot from that company,
and other companies who
operate in a similar fashion.
Constraint is a big thing for me,
and this is something that
we're constantly learning
not to fear, as well.
It's important to say no.
And it's important to be
able to easily say no.
And there's many, many things you can do.
Especially when you have
a successful venture
behind you, or you're running with it.
And it's really important
to recognize, you know,
when, where you need to
go, where you'd like to go,
and really constrain the process,
and then keep things really simple.
In my dispatch days,
back in 1999, or in 2000,
we built something really cool.
We loved it.
And then we hired a CEO
that didn't really match
our personalities and
didn't match our vision,
and we grew the company
very, very quickly.
And that really scattered
the focus of the company,
so one of the things I've
learned from Twitter is
that, you know, that singular focus,
that do one thing
- Yeah.
- And do it very well.
That works out.
I think the biggest thing for me,
I think for all startups,
is that it's really, really easy to
consider any hire as, like,
the length of the entire company.
I think leaders of companies
have to consider themselves editors.
And you constantly have to edit the team.
You constantly have to make sure
that you have the best people in,
and if there's any negative attribute
within the team, person
or element or otherwise,
you have to part ways.
- [Interviewer] And
deal with it right away.
- Yeah, right away.
I mean, you have to say, like,
"This is the best thing for the company,
"and to be fair to both us, like,
it's just not the right
time for both of us."
Like any other relationship,
you need to be able to
recognize what's good
and what isn't optimal
and take action on it.
So that's one thing that, you know,
like with Twitter, we
grew very very slowly,
and we didn't edit the
team in the best way.
We didn't get out of the way
of ourselves often enough.
That's something I would never do again.
What I want to talk to you about today
is a note which I call "Daily."
So if you create a new
note, in your notepad,
or something that you
check on a daily basis,
this is the most important thing.
Name it "Daily."
And then write the word "Do:"
And then go down a few lines
and write the word "Don't:"
The one thing I would ask you to do,
walking out of this, is
to, every single day,
just for a week, wake up to this note,
check it throughout the day,
and then also before you fall asleep,
check to make sure that you did
and you didn't do everything.
So what you put in each one of these
is you have a list of everything
that you want to do every single day.
And you have a list of things
that you don't want to do.
And the easiest way to add to the don'ts
is to notice something that
you never want to do it again.
You never want to do again,
and you just add that to it.
Very, very simple.
I'm just going to share some of mine;
these might be a little bit
personal and embarrassing,
but here we are.
Number one on my "do" list
is to stay present.
I think it's so easy to
get trapped in the past.
It's so easy to think about the future.
The most important
thing is I stay present,
and just reading this brings
me back to the present,
brings me back to this moment.
Number two for me is be vulnerable.
Show people my mistakes,
show people my fears,
because they can relate.
Because they're going
through similar things.
Number three: drink only
lemon water and red wine.
(crowd laughs)
Great red wine is a great modifier for it.
This goes with one of my "don'ts",
which is "don't drink hard
liquor or beer on weekdays."
(audience laughs)
Number three is six sets
of 20 squats and push-ups.
Throughout the day.
I just have to do them every day.
Six sets of 30 second planks.
Run for three miles.
Meditate on this list.
Stand up straight.
Which, whenever I say,
I always see posture
moving in the audience.
Say hello to everyone.
I just bought a heavy bag,
so I'm training with a heavy bag,
so I want to spend ten minutes
with the heavy bag every day.
I'm going to do a video
journal every single day.
And I want to get seven hours of sleep.
On my "don't" list; and again,
this is one of the hardest things,
and a lot of these are personal,
so I'm not going to read all of them.
But on my "don't" list is
don't avoid eye contact.
Don't be late.
Don't set expectations for
someone and not meet them.
Don't eat sugar.
I'm on the paleo diet, so don't eat
wheat, lentils, or dairy.
And then, of course, don't
drink hard liquor or beer.
On the weekdays.
So this list, while it
sounds very, very simple,
has been fundamental in
establishing patterns for myself.
And it's something that I do
check every single morning.
I check throughout the day,
and I check right before I go to bed.
And I make sure that
I check everything off
and go through it.
I've given it to our companies.
I've given it to a number of
students that I've talked to
as we've gone to schools and recruiting.
And people have come back to me and said,
"This is something that works for me."
It's something that's easy to do,
and something easy to remember.
One of the most
fundamental things about it
that I've learned, that
I've taken away from it,
is how it gives you focus.
How it gives you something that
allows you to really ignore
everything else that's going on.
All the other noise.
To allow you to focus on
what's most important.
So this "do and don't" list, for people,
and individuals in the company,
has translated to a do and don't list
for our company.
For Square, we have a do and don't list.
We have "these are the things
that we're going to do,"
"these are our core things,"
"these are our bold bets,"
and "these are the things we're
saying no to for right now."
It's been fundamental in
allowing us to move fast,
to continue to innovate,
and to really push the boundaries
and continue and invent
and question and reset
everything that we think
about the organization.
And one of my greatest
lessons that I learned
in starting and running Twitter
and starting and running Square,
which is how important it is
to instrument all usage.
You have to instrument everything.
For the first two years of Twitter's life,
we were flying blind.
We had no idea what was
going with the network,
we had no idea what was
going on with the system,
with how people were using it.
We were making guesses,
we were basing everything on intuition
instead of having a good balance
between intuition and data.
And we were going down all
the time because of it.
Because we could not
see what was happening.
So the first thing I wrote for Square,
on the server, was an admin dashboard.
And we have very, very strong discipline
within the company,
which is now 72 people,
to log everything, to measure everything,
and to test everything.
And we treat the dashboard,
we treat the analytics,
we treat the data, as a product.
And we call it the Inference Team,
and their job is to instrument all usage,
and infer all action.
And that's something that we need,
but it's also something
that our users need.
"Art, when really understood,
"is a province of every human being.
"It is simply a question of
doing things, anything, well.
"It is not an outside, extra thing.
"When the artist is alive in any person,
"whatever his kind of work may be,
"he becomes an inventive,
searching, daring,
"self-expressing creature.
"He becomes interesting to other people.
"He disturbs, upsets, enlightens,
"and he opens ways for
better understanding.
"Where those who are not artists
"are trying to close
the book, he opens it.
"He shows there are still
more pages possible."
And I think that's so
telling for everything
that you all are about to do,
all the challenges you're about to face.
You're going to be the
ones that open the book.
"The world would stagnate without him,
"and the world would
be beautiful with him;
"for he is interesting to himself
"and he is interesting to others.
"He does not have to be
a painter or a sculptor
"to be an artist.
"He can work in any medium.
"He simply has to find the
gain in the work itself,
"not outside of it."
And one of the biggest
lessons that I've learned
throughout my career is
how important the work is.
How important not just the end product is,
but the actual craft.
Doing the work.
Inventing within the work.
"The work of the art
student is no light matter.
"Few have the courage and
stamina to see it through.
"You have to make up your
mind to be alone in many ways.
"We like sympathy, as humans,
and we like to be in company.
"It is easier than going it alone.
"But alone one gets
acquainted with himself,
"grows up and on, not
stopping with the crowd.
"It costs to do this.
"If you succeed somewhat
you may have to pay for it
"as well as enjoy it for
the rest of your life."
And that's something, if
you do something meaningful,
you are going to have to
pay for it in all the work,
but at the same time you
will also be able to enjoy it
for the rest of your life.
"We are not here to do what
has already been done."
Everyone in this room feels that;
we are not here to do what
has already been done.
"Know what the old masters did.
"Know how they composed their pictures,
"but do not fall into the
conventions they established.
"These conventions were right for them,
"and they are wonderful.
"They made their language.
"You make yours.
"They can help you.
"All the past can help you."
And I think in Silicon Valley,
especially in technology,
it's so easy to fall in
the footsteps of others.
To do what they do because
you think it's the right way
because you think they've had the success
and you can copy that success.
You have to find your own path.
You have to find your own footsteps.
"An art student must be a
master from the beginning;
"that is, he must be
master of such as he has.
"By being now master of such
as he has there is promise
"that he will be a master in the future."
What he means by this is purely,
you have to be a master of your own tools.
That mastership is not a destination,
it is a process, and
it's constant practice
that gets you there.
"It is not enough to
have thought great things
"before doing the work."
We have so many ideas,
but what really matters is the work
to implement those ideas.
"Don't worry about the rejections.
"Everybody that's good
has gone through it.
"Don't let it matter if your works
"are not 'accepted' at once.
"The better or more personal you are
"the less likely they are of acceptance.
"Just remember that the
object of painting pictures
"is not simply to get them in exhibition.
"It is all very fine to
have your pictures hung,
"but you are painting for
yourself, not for the jury."
And what's meaningful
about this passage to me is
we work so hard to get some
sort of acceptance in the world.
To get some sort of positive feedback.
And we look at others, and it
seems so fast, their success.
It seems like they did
it in just a moment.
But it takes years, and years,
and years, and patience.
The marking interface is not easy on this.
"There's a time and place for all things;
"the difficulty is to use them only
"in their proper time and place."
There's a time and place for all things.
The difficulty is to use them only
in their proper time and place.
"With motive, you will
become clairvoyant of means,
"you will seize and command them.
"Without motive, you will wobble about."
This, in building a team,
in building an organization,
in building a company, is
one of the greatest lessons.
You cannot do anything without
a shared and common sense of purpose.
If you don't have motive,
if you don't have purpose
that is shared between everyone,
you will wander about.
You will wobble.
And you will not do
anything of infinite means,
you will not do anything that is timeless.
And lastly:
"The art student of
these days is a pioneer."
Just like all of you.
"The art student of today must pioneer
"beyond the mere matters of fact.
"I believe the great artists of the future
"will use fewer words, copy fewer things.
"Essays will be shorter in words,
"and longer in meaning."
I love this passage.
"I believe the great artists of the future
"will use fewer words, copy fewer things.
"Essays will be shorter in
words and longer in meaning.
"We must paint only
what is important to us.
"We must not respond to outside demands.
"They do not know what they want
"or what we have to give."
I think one of the most important things
about what all of you do
is that you are building what
you want to see in the world.
You're making the bet that other people
want to see the same thing in the world.
Sometimes you lose the bet,
sometimes you win the bet.
But the most important thing is you have
that passion to build for yourself,
because that is what's infectious,
and that is what brings other people
to your cause and to your team.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I hope you enjoyed this video.
I made it because Digvijay asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know,
what did Jack say that
really inspired you,
that motivated you, that made you think
or question something?
Leave it in the comments,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you soon.
- [Man With Red Shirt] How do you go about
attracting funding and then
managing your investors
after you've secured it?
- [Jack] I think the thing
that's always worked for me
is realizing that...
Your investors are...
First and foremost, I
always want to go to anyone
that I want to work with
with something to show.
And it was really important to us,
before we talked to any investors,
on the Twitter side, that
we actually had people
using the service at some scale.
And on the Square side, we actually
had a working prototype.
At Square we had, really, seven merchants
when we actually went to raise money.
But we had a working prototype
that people were actually using.
If people can't see it and feel it,
it's very, very hard to sell.
I don't want to just go and tell people,
"This is going to be
the biggest thing ever."
I want to be able to show that,
and have them feel it and walk
away feeling that as well.
So that's first and foremost,
is have something to show.
So that they can actually feel
and start making it a part
of their story as well
and feel like they have ownership over it.
And then second is the realization, like,
I always kind of approach this as, like...
If we take money from someone,
this is kind of like hiring
someone that we can never fire.
We can never get rid of, right?
So that means, do we really
want to work with this person?
Is this person going to
be someone that really
pushes us in the way that
we need to be pushed?
And you can tell that fairly quickly.
In that first week of pitching Square,
got a lot of people who said,
"Okay, great, we don't have any questions,
"we'll get back to you
in about 30 minutes,
"probably with a term sheet."
And I said, "I don't want a term sheet.
Especially if you're not
asking any questions."
'Cause they asked no
questions during the pitch.
And that means if they're on our board
that they're actually not going to be
all that constructive in terms of really
asking the tough questions and making sure
that we're, you know, we're
not just in our own bubble,
but they're looking outside.
That is the role of the Board,
is to look outside and bring all their
insight and wisdom to us,
so that we can help guide the company.
And that second week, we got
a lot of tough questions,
and that's what I love,
because I know if I'm getting
tough questions in the pitch,
I'm going to get tough questions
in the boardroom as well.
And not just the
boardroom, but every week.
I mean, Vinod emails me once a week about,
"Have you thought about this?
"Are you doing this?"
And, you know, "I know this person,
"can I make an introduction here?"
And it's just very, very useful.
So I'm looking for someone
who I just love working with.
And I think you have to
set a very, very high bar,
it's not just about money
or the firm, it's about the
individual that you're
ultimately going to work with.
And people ask me all the time, you know,
"What firms would you suggest I go pitch?"
I'm like, find the people that
you really want to work with
in those firms and if
there's someone that just
really resonates with
you and you love the idea
of working with them, focus on them.
And if it tests out to be the case, great.
But I think you have to
kind of treat it as like,
I'm adding this person to my team.
One of the biggest things
that has helped me
is learning how to become
a better storyteller,
and the power of a story.
And by this I mean,
if you want to build a product,
and you want to build a product
that is relevant to folks,
you need to put yourself in their shoes.
And you need to write a
story from their side.
So we spend a lot of time writing
what's called "user narratives."
Of "this user," or "this person"
"is in the middle of Chicago,
and they go to a coffee store
in the middle of Chicago,
and this is the experience
they're going to have."
It reads like a play.
It's really, really beautiful.
And if you do that story well,
then all the prioritization,
all of the product,
all of the design, and
all the coordination
that you need to do with these products
just falls out naturally.
Because you can edit the story,
and everyone can relate to the story
from all levels of the organization;
engineers, to operations,
to support, to designers,
to, you know, the business
side of the house.
So that story is very,
very important for us.
And really constantly
considering the story
and what new twists and elements
we need to add to the story
are a pretty big deal for us, as well.
And we want to tell an epic story.
We want to solve a really big problem.
We don't want to have a bunch
of short stories strung together.
We want one epic, cohesive story
that we tell the world.
And both Twitter and Square
are driving towards this goal.
So number two, good storytelling,
and writing stories for the users.
- [Interviewer] Who's your favorite CEO?
- [Jack] Who's my favorite CEO...
- [Interviewer] Who's your role model?
- I always look up to
Steve Jobs.
- Steve Jobs?
(chuckling)
- I know it's a common one, but
I think that's for a reason.
I think he's done some amazing things.
He has a great pacing about him.
You know, there are a
lot of horror stories.
He is a very opinionated person.
But he has the direction,
and he knows what he wants to do.
And he does it.
- Yeah.
- And he makes sure that when, you know,
he's not so good in there,
he recognizes it and he fills that area.
And that's really important
for any CEO, I think,
is to recognize your weaknesses
and bring amazing people.
And bring people in
that are much smarter--
- [Interviewer] Smarter than you.
- And you know, just create
a creative work environment.